is zero road fatality in Europe a
fantasy or will it happen sooner than we
think
Europe's roads already are the safest in
the world still more than 25,000 people
died in road accidents every year in the
EU the European Parliament wants to
reduce this toll by making driver
assistance systems mandatory in all new
vehicles you begin Fila as kuffara as
for stinger as Farhad forum when Johnson
fajas 10 sistema and for Stila by father
the her friend zone wouldn't fill it to
for Maidan human error is responsible
for more than 92 percent of all road
accidents what exactly are these driver
assistance systems they're things like
braking systems detecting pedestrians
and cyclists truck turning assistance
and cameras to reduce risks of blind
spots or lane keeping assistance the
only problem is cost but lawmakers argue
that that can be overcome if you make it
as a kid I saw and I'll do a nice
thinkin or and you're either when
mustn't be so far assistances tamarang
about the ardent that like you hadn't
you thought so a good mystery instantly
toy over you I can't find Vinnie and
there are bonuses these tech innovations
can also reduce fuel consumption
optimize traffic flows and help create
jobs
[Music]